six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty is the number let's go to
our caller from the nine seven eight
area code who's calling today from nine
seven eight
hello this is Steve hey Steve what's
going on hey how you doing um so I'm a
mass resident I guess I consider myself
more of a libertarian than anything else
okay
and kind of being a libertarian I think
my general nature has always been to
kind of be a person that's in the middle
or tries to see things from the middle
and I can typically appreciate both
points of views so forth and so on and
one of the things that I'm struggling
with in general yeah is this
polarization towards party and the fact
that we seem to be in this pattern where
once one party takes office or takes
seemingly takes control of things they
reign supreme and they basically
steamroll over the other party
completely at the expense of it and of
course there's always some sort of moral
or other justification for doing so okay
so let's explore whether that's if we're
gonna discuss that we should explore
whether that's the case what's an
example of how for example the Obama
administration steamrolled Republicans
and did stuff all right so I'm a person
that might memory with things in general
just day-to-day life things honestly is
just like terrible so I mean when I have
to recall something I mean I can't even
remember my kids birthdays for crying
out loud so it's very difficult for me
to just do that kind of stuff in general
okay fair sigh I guess what I was trying
to get to is I simply don't think that
it happens the way you're saying it
happens so let me give you the Obama
example President Obama became president
of the United States in 2008 he was
inaugurated in 2009 he had the House and
Senate for those first two years until
the Tea Party surge took took over
control of I guess it was just the house
in in 2010 2010 what was he able to do
it's like okay he got Obamacare passed
which was a center-right idea from a
conservative think tank from the 90s
which gave tens of millions of new
customers to for-profit insurance
companies we had Sandy Hook and yes in
message in Romneycare we had Sandy Hook
and like 90% consensus in the US that we
need 100% universal background checks he
still wasn't able to get it done so I
just really he was he had a Supreme
Court pick which Republicans just said
yeah we're not even gonna hold
confirmation hearing so I don't see any
steamrolling that the part that the
quote president in power was able to
even do okay so so certainly when is
certainly there are interesting dynamics
when when you have like like a Congress
and the executive branch that are that
are aligned and you would think then
that they would just simply get their
way and do everything well there's
there's a funny dynamic that seems to
happen where the parties all of a sudden
become aware of that and that opens the
door for them to be you know more
polarizing towards things that are going
on let's say in their own state their
own constituency and stuff and that kind
of infighting
prevents additional things from
potentially happening but Steve isn't
that aren't you conceding that it's
actually the opposite you said your
concern is a party gets a party wins the
White House and then they steamroll
everybody in the other party I kind of
gave a counter example saying well it
didn't happen under Obama and you're
saying oh right yeah because when one
party's in power they start infighting
and they still actually don't really get
that much done that that's kind of the
opposite of your initial argument isn't
it which I'm glad that we're figuring
out I'm not criticizing you I'm just
saying it seems that you're agreeing
with me that it doesn't quite happen the
way you suggested well I think I think
to some extent that that's true okay and
and I'm well I'm certainly willing to
concede that but so I think the thing
with with steamrolling and here's kind
of what I mean like this this this
notion of you know both you know
branches kind of the they have these
committees and they go off and they they
work and you know creating some sort of
bill that they hope becomes a law and
they do it by themselves they're in
these their own little echo chambers
whether it's a you know Democratic
whether it's Republican or whatever and
they come out knowing full well that the
op that the other side is going to have
supreme opposition to it yes and then
try to push that through I come from a
base where
I like collaboration and compromise so
for example and you know we have things
with you know voter ID we have things
with you know guns and gun controls and
stuff an example of a collaboration in
my point of view in other words work and
we're gonna genuinely consider the other
party's point of view their need so
forth and so on might be you know what
why don't we try to pass things like
like voter ID but while we also try to
pass things like gun reform where we
have you know the extensive background
checks where we make sure that people
yeah are truly registered not in
licensed and they know all about weapon
safety and stuff I'll tell you why
because that's exactly how we end up in
these situations where you have a bill
about voter ID where the opposition
party says let's stuff some things about
gun control in there and then the other
party says hey that doesn't really have
anything to do with what we're doing and
the other party says well if you don't
pass my gun control thing I'm not gonna
it we've seen that that already is what
they try to do and it just doesn't
really work that well it creates a
different type of gridlock I appreciate
what you're saying I am always you know
I would make I would I would suggest
people re-examine the eye if they see
themselves as the sort of enlightened
centrists who could make everybody come
together I would read a little bit of
the history of American politics over
the last 40 years to realize it's not
it's not quite so simple I got to move
on but I appreciate the phone call Steve
sure thank you all right take care